this morning on the dish chicago chef
joe flam he's known to food fans
nationwide after winning the top chef
cooking competition in 2018 and now he's
put that talent to use at one of
chicago's hottest new restaurants his
rosemary in the fulton market
neighborhood isn't your typical fair
blending the cuisines of italy and
croatia and he invited us to sample some
of his best
seasonal creations
in this former meatpacking district just
off the chicago river
is a culinary voyage to the sun-drenced
shores of the dalmatian coast
at rosemary dishes exploring italian
croatian cuisine bring with faraway
flavors yet familiar experiences
helmed by chef joe flam so you say that
you serve adriatic drinking food what is
that exactly it's either things that
make you you know kind of thirsty to
have a glass of wine or things you would
want to have with some wine or things
maybe you would have because you've had
a little bit too much wine it's a
distinct craving inspired by traveling
flam aims to satisfy one plate at a time
that's what we wanted this to be that
place where you walked by you felt an
energy coming off and you're like we got
to go in you stop in and you have that
moment in time right the ambitious
target is rooted in flames love of both
his native chicago and family rosemary
is named after his grandmother's as well
as the frequent herb that grows along
the coast of italy and croatia where his
wife's family is from the connective
tissue between those two places
is so rich and thick you don't need to
fuse the two they've already been doing
it for hundreds of years that journey
includes the croatian staple of grilled
clams but in true windy city fashion
flames are dressed in butter married
with smoke ramps a type of wild onion
said to have given chicago its name
cheers
do you do that with clams
that's very good flam also prefers to
start a big feast with the little gem
salad you get the sweet brightness of
the radishes that come through a little
bit of that kind of salty nuttiness from
the cheese and then that like creamy
just buttery kaimak underneath that it's
just like that rich almost like you know
ranch dressing quality to it of you know
a proper midwestern salad you're trying
to evoke ranch dressing in your own way
we are who we are we know who we are
here we're not afraid of it
[Laughter]
then there are hearty favorites like the
pork ribs papanella and scradine risotto
known as 12-hour risotto for the time it
takes to perfect inspired by flam's
wife's family recipe we braise veal
brass we pick it we take that liquid we
cook the rice down with that parmigiano
grilled chicken thighs on top of it
that's a lot of flavor to pack into one
dish it is and not a single drop of that
flavor is to be wasted which is why flam
bakes bread with a recipe native to
croatia fresh each morning this is our
house made with gingerbread so this took
us a really long time to figure out
there's not a lot of places that make
the spread it's shaped like a pita it's
kind of cooked like a pita but it's also
the interior structure that's completely
different it's got the chewing crumb of
a real like bread and then we use this
as just a mop for pastas a bread mop is
just my favorite kind of mom
that bread and much of the ever evolving
menu is prepared on a charcoal hearth
custom designed and inspired by the
large grills flamwoods spot at roadside
canopus cozy taverns dotting the
croatian coast
their smoke would often remind flam of
barbecue in chicago summertime you're
talking about bringing in midwestern
hospitality into a restaurant that
specializes in italian croatian food
yeah but i think those all connect i
think that you know very italian style
of hospitality is also that midwest
style fatality it's welcoming it's warm
it's you know inviting people want you
to eat they want you to stay a sense of
being home even as flam introduces a new
cuisine to diners croatian cuisine
really isn't known that much in the
united states and i think that was part
of the thing that interested me about it
i was like
this food is familiar i was like i feel
like i could cook this it was like you
know not saying like oh i'm you know the
foremost expert on bulk and cuisine now
but of like
i know how to cook italian food and i
want to use it to tell a story that i'm
also trying to find out i think it's
interesting that you call these dishes
stories i love cooking with people and
just listening to them like oh why are
you cooking this years of cooking with
my grandmother
and
spending time in the kitchen with her
flam calls his italian grandmother mary
his first culinary influence before
going on to train in some of chicago's
top restaurants
including michelin starred spiaja and
stephanie izzard's girl in the goat he's
also cooked in some of italy's top
kitchens refining his skills to bring
classics back home we're making catchy
pepe today one of my favorites tetrapepe
is so simple but sometimes really hard
to perfect
well i think anything that's simple
there's nothing to hide behind right so
it's all technique flam's technique also
includes a sense of hospitality hard to
miss
is there such thing as too much cheese
think of a midwestern amount of cheese
oh well then let's just get that on yeah
that's perfect
that generous spirit helped vault
rosemary instantly into one of chicago's
hottest reservations when it opened its
doors last spring what has this journey
meant to you
i mean everything we're literally
sitting in my dream right now i get to
do something that i love that i'm super
passionate about it's part you know this
little community and this industry is so
important
how is the south side of chicago shaped
you it's definitely very much hawaii
it's in your blood you're from there you
live there you die there it's it's who
we are it's a tight-knit community it's
community focused it's family focused
for flam that determination has paid
dividends one of the grandmothers that
your restaurant is named after has been
here yeah uh my grandma mary she doesn't
live far from here she comes in quite a
bit what does it mean to her that you
named this restaurant after her well you
know i'm one of 24 grandchildren on that
side so i think i'm just trying to
cement my position as number one
grandchild do you think you've done that
oh yeah for sure for sure
it's not even close
for sure and by the way i brought some
food back with me from chicago we have
some lupinja bread because you saw me
get lost in that and yeah catch you pepe
so please enjoy
for those of you still with us
you're enjoying it you can watch us eat
but more importantly
hear more about i love the midwestern
helping of cheese oh it's a lot of
cheese yeah there's so so much this is
good but this is the kachoke that uh you
know we brought back here with us i
thought it was really interesting
because i asked him is this a fusion of
the two cuisines but it really is
something that celebrates croatian
cuisine as it is and italian cuisine as
it is and he uses a lot of local
ingredients uh so you have that chicago
feeling to this food that is thousands
of miles away
i understand now why you got lost in the
bread because i'm lost in it right now
and i'm talking with my mouth because
it's still oh it's good oh good nothing
like getting lost in bread
well i was well if you could get lost in
the cockpit yeah you could
even better we have tequila tendencies
is fresh yes it is it has a simple syrup
grapefruit juice lime juice but tequila
is really the same oh yeah it's got some
tequila in there yeah wow wow oh that is
a really good pour
i love that he said he's one of 20
grandkids and and he's just trying to
cement himself and he's done it you name
you name a restaurant after a
grandmother you are vaulted you get it
that's right yeah i love it but it's you
know it's it's also really interesting
just because a lot of people do not know
croatian food in the united states to be
able to explore something that's
different even if it's negative 10
degrees in chicago to be able to travel
someplace through food right oh
excellent great job nancy